there's a difference between the
censorship in the US and the censorship
in Brazil okay the the big Tech
censorship in the United States is
private is protected by the First
Amendment it's something no one knows
how to fix yet but it's I own Twitter
I'm Elon Musk I want you out of my
company it's the same thing you don't
have to offer service to someone you
don't want to to to be your customer
okay it's one thing we we have to
discuss that but in Brazil you have that
but you also have
uh something that we didn't used to and
it's against the law in Brazil because
we have the courts
banishing people from social media and
not even the cards sometimes only
Alexander de mores own decision like one
guy and says take it off
is it true that it is a crime now to
doubt the outcome of the election it's
it's not a crime you can contest it's
legal to do that and the the the person
the bolsonaro's party just did that
officially yesterday right it's a big
news in Brazil right now so they did it
and it's legal the problem is that uh
and Alexandra de mores is treating
everyone that contests or complains
about it as a criminal and the mean the
mainstream media is with him it's at his
side we got to give you some context
here to to understand because that's a
tough question okay so back on the on
the history the little story I was
telling uh so when bolsonaro got elected
and the system one knots The
Establishment when nuts the first thing
one of the first thing that the Supreme
Court started doing was they created a
probe against fake news Okay that was
fake news probe and they did it in a
very weird way
because Brazil has the same accusatory
system which is a Bedrock of the western
world uh due process of law so what's
the accusatory system you have uh
investigator an accuser an impartial
judge a defendant and victims everyone
is separated everyone that different
different agents playing different roles
so the Supreme Court they did something
that was never seen them never seen in
Brazil they opened the probe saying oh
there's a something on our internal
regimen or internal bylaws of the of the
of the Supreme Court saying that if a
crime happens inside Supreme Court
premises we can open an investigation we
can open a probe
so right now uh internet if someone says
something bad about us that's kind of
like it happened inside our court and
it's kind of an attack a crime and it's
people are criticizing us it's kind of
like an attack yeah attack to our
reputation they are a threat to
democracy because they are criticizing
us that's really what's going on I'm not
I'm not making this up I'm not making
this up it's hard to believe so they
were the victims of an attack
so they opened the investigator the
investigation and they brought a federal
police chief directly to report to them
so they were
they had control of the investigation as
well so they were the victims the
investigators they were also so the the
Department of Justice refused to take
part in in it because there's no crime
of fake news or whatever in Brazil so
they said no this is this whole thing is
is all illegal and you can't open an
investigation and we're not taking part
of it so they said okay we're going to
do it without you so and it's like what
the constitution in Brazil says you can
only prosecute someone with the
Department of Justice it was the same as
in the U.S a judge can as much as
generals Flynn General Flynn's Justice
judge uh tried to prosecute them he
couldn't because the Department of
Justice refused to prosecute him so same
thing in Brazil by the law so and and
again they did that
and they did a second one and then they
did it again they they came up with a
very similar one anti-democratic acts
about people demonstrating on the
streets and they were like this is
anti-democratic because you're asking
for a military intervention you're
you're protesting against institutions
so that's against democracy but there's
no under Brazilian Constitution you do
have one the right of free speech
two it's the the prior censorship is
forbidden you can't do it government can
uh impose prior censorship to no
individuals there's no crime of fake
news there's none on Brazilian they
tried to pass a legislation and they
failed if they make it yeah uh and and
but with all that they decided to do it
anyways so they started coming after and
without the due process they started to
arrest
journalists journalists congressmen
Congressman there was a congressman that
was arrested because of a crime of
opinion Community organizers they all
started to be arrested so and that that
started in the fake news probe and then
the anti-democratic probe all that that
happened and they they went after even
businessmen big businessmen I'm talking
for example the guy that owns the
biggest small uh chain and probably
Latin America and a huge investment here
by the way a huge investment here in the
U.S so I'm talking about a guy that owns
a like big retail stores like Sears in
Brazil uh they they started going after
supporters of personaro journalists
congressmen businessmen and and without
due process because they were not being
charged currently in the U.S there's a
guy living here in Florida
a guy named Alan DeSantis this guy is a
journalist he used to have the biggest
Independent News Channel in Brazil okay
YouTube channel
it was a business that was doing well
and this guy he's being investigated
under under Alessandro de Morris probe
the fake news uh well then they changed
the fake news to digital militia's uh
probe which they they switched the name
but it's the same thing
uh and militia in Brazil doesn't mean
the same thing as in the US it's it's
like a gang it's like an organized gang
um but I'll understand they just took
his passport this way yes they canceled
his passport they issued an arrest
warrant against him he was in the U.S so
he stayed here he's under political
asylum in the United States right now uh
he uh he they froze in all his accounts
they closed his Media Company
and and right now is in the United
States and that's The Best Is Yet To
Come Paulo is given a the whole View and
it's because you asked a tough question
yes is it illegal and I would say let me
know it's not illegal but it is but it
is in Practical terms let me give you
one example that one one huge uh
entrepreneur in Brazil uh the police
came to his office at six o'clock in the
morning seven o'clock in the morning his
crime was in a in a WhatsApp group
closed group they were talking about
Lula and the possibilities of Lula going
back to Power and the guy one of them
said oh I rather live in a dictatorship
than that and the guy like sent a like
alike and that's it like if you liked it
he likes the message the message and the
police was at his place get out of here
and his and he's a private WhatsApp
group
wait wait wait a billionaire liked the
post I'd rather have a dictator not a
post
with the military government yeah what's
up relatives I'd rather have a military
government than having this in office I
was part of the group I was part of I
was in the group and that's it no one's
no one was talking about a coupe there
was no uh a strategy of being built
nothing it was just complaining about
Lula so with all the craziness taking
place I believe future looks bright if
you believe future looks bright get your
latest Future looks bright hat of
valuetainment it says future looks
bright here future looks bright here we
got them in white we got them in Black
we got them in red or black on black
sold out these are about to sell out if
you haven't ordered one yet we had a
person in Michigan but one then he
bought three then when those three
people weren't in the office they had to
order 58 of them because people wanted
the future looks bright hat especially
during times like this because ain't
nobody's saying future looks spread
toward your future looks bright hat
click over here and to watch the entire
podcast click here take care everybody
[Music]